concernés par le dispositif pénibilité
de pouvoir bénéficier d'un rescrit
spécifiques dont l'objectif serait de
valider les modifie les modalités
d'application des modes d'emploi ou tout
référentiel dead l'évaluation des
risques professionnels qui seront fixées
par arrêté conjoint des ministres
chargés du travail et des affaires
sociales ce rescrit incombe à la caisse
chargée de la liquidation des pensions
de retraite du régime général carsat en
effet la loi du 20 janvier 2014
garantissant l'avenir et la justice du
système de retraite a confié la gestion
de ce dispositif à la cnav et aux
réseaux des carsat ainsi il appartient
logiquement au carsat d'effectuer ou de
faire effectuer des contrôle de
l'effectivité de l'exposition au risque
sur place ou sur pièce tel est l'objet
du présent amendement
amendement numéro 44 actifs y était
représentée par monsieur cardio
oui madame la présidente monsieur
minutes chers collègues cet amendement
vient en complément tout à fait utile de
l'amendement que nous avons défendues
précédemment toujours en faveur des
petites entreprises parce que nous
savons tous pour ceux qui pratiquent qui
côtoient les patrons de pme que la pire
des choses pour eux et sur un texte
nouveau de prendre des positions parfois
conseillé par des experts compétents et
de s'entendre dire un an deux ans ou
trois ans après par l'administration
fiscale ou l'administration sociale qui
eux ont eu le temps à la fois d'étudier
les textes et surtout de prendre la
tâche de leur direction pour savoir
quelle position prendra banon vous êtes
trompé c'était effectivement une
disposition nouvelle vous êtes trompés
alors la conséquence de votre erreur
même si vous êtes de bonne foi et bien
c'est en ces temps avec certaines fois
des sommes considérables mises à leur
charge et qui peuvent aller jusqu'à la
cessation de paiement des entreprises
qui sont confrontés à une telle
situation
alors cette procédure de rescrit en
matière du conte pénibilité viendrait
utilement compléter la procédure
simplifiée de déclaration par la donnée
par la déclaration annuelle des salaires
puisque ça permettrait une entreprise
qui douterait
la pertinence de son choix et de la
transmission des informations
concernant ces salariés de questionner
les caisses d'assurance vieillesse pour
savoir si oui ou non la position qu'elle
a choisi la meilleure et à partir de là
de lui donner une sécurité juridique sur
le fût le futur d'appliquer la position
qu'a pris la caisse et de surtout d'être
certaine de ne pas être redressée sur
une disposition qu'elle avait considéré
prise comme de bonne foi donc je pense
que ces deux amendements sont tout à
fait complémentaires et serait de nature
à considérablement sécuriser les
entreprises moins de 10 salariés quant à
l'application des dispositions
très compliquée du conte pénibilité
je vais demander l'avis de la commission
des affaires sociales sur tout d'abord
les deux premiers amendements la réponse
est inquiète et locales
l'avis de la commission est favorable à
ces amendements de suppression comme je
l'avais exprimé je pensais que ces
amendements relevait peut-être davantage
du plfss et de la branche vieillesse
mais effectivement ça concerne aussi des
conséquences sur la vie de l'entreprise
et si les décrets en particulier tout ce
qui pose problème en pour 2016 n'était
pas sorti
avant lui l analyse de ce texte en ici
au sénat nous n'aurions peut-être pas
mes collègues n'aurait peut-être pas
souhaité déposer ses amendements et les
voter donc je dois en donner l'avis
favorable de la commission à cette
suppression de ces deux amendements
je continue
madame la présidente pour l'amendement
de rectifier quelques aces et 43
rectifié terre alors l'amendement de
rectifier l'amendement 43 sont des
amendements qui me paraissent aller dans
le sens de la loi de simplification
puisque le gouvernement a bien dit dans
l'objet de cette loi qu'il voulait
simplifier le fonctionnement des
entreprises utiliser davantage
l'internet
l'utilisation de la déclaration de la
dsn la déclaration sociale nominative
est effectivement un pas vers cette
simplification
sans compter qu effectivement comme le
dit un de nos collègues la fiche
individuelle suppose une modification
des logiciels de gestion du personnel
qui interviendrait avant l'application
de l'adsl il ya effectivement des vrais
problèmes
je pense que ces deux amendements vont
dans le sens et vont même dans l'esprit
du texte
avis favorable de la commission et nous
poursuivons avec les deux suivantes 3
rectifié qu'inquiets ses 44 rectifié
terre 44 qui sont sur des procédure de
rescrit aussi
le projet de loi veut développer les
procédure de rescrit et il me semble que
ces amendements sont des amendements de
repli et en même temps des amendements
qui permettrait effectivement de de
simplifier la vie des entreprises et de
s'inscrire dans l'esprit de la loi à vis
du gouvernement sur ces amendements
donc nous reprenons à rectifier 15,42
rectifié contre oui madame la présence
de d'abord salué la créativité du du
sénat et des sénateurs pour se
débarrasser de ce compte
pénibilité
est
allé au fond
de cette discussion avant que de
m'exprimer plus précisément sur
l'avis défavorable du gouvernement à
l'ensemble de ces amendements sur le
fond ce dispositif qui a été créée par
la loi
du 20 janvier 2014 n'est pas un
dispositif contrairement à ce que cela à
ce qui a été dit unique en europe
des
politiques de prise en compte de la
pénibilité datera du travail et de
bonification
pour les droits à la retraite des
travaux pénibles existe dans d'autres
pays européens je cite par exemple
l'allemagne où ce dispositif existe
depuis des années et où ce dispositif
tout quelqu'un dit tout à l'heure ça
n'existe nulle part où ce dispositif
fonctionne très bien il fonctionne très
bien car un peu d'histoire y compris qui
nous a amenés à proposer ce texte de loi
en janvier 2014 il fonctionne très bien
car il est le résultat d'une négociation
entre partenaires sociaux qui a abouti
en allemagne et qui en france n'a pas
abouti et si nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes c'est parce que il y a quelques
années deux ans et demi pour être très
précis alors que les partenaires sociaux
avaient négocié en france depuis des
mois la mise en place d'un dispositif
de pénibilité alors qu'ils étaient
arrivés à un accord
l'un des partenaires sociaux en l'espèce
ils le reconnaissent d'ailleurs bien
volontiers eux mêmes quand on les
interroge et j'imagine que vous l'avez
fait le représentant les représentants
patronaux ont fait volte-face et ont
finalement refusé de
signé l'accord qu'ils avaient négocié et
accepté dans un premier temps avec les
partenaires sociaux et voilà quelque
chose qui est au coeur des
problématiques dont nous parlons toute
cette soirée la question de la fabrique
de la loi la question d'une d'un droit
nouveau qui est créé qui pourrait être
appliquable gagne à être enrichie par la
participation des parties prenantes
c'est à dire en l'espèce des partenaires
sociaux parce que nous n'avons pas pu
faire ce travail parce que les
parlementaires ont été privés de la
possibilité de l'apport par la
négociation sociale qu'aurait représenté
un accord des partenaires sociaux ils
ont dû se substituer à cette carence
pour définir un droit nouveau qui donne
aux salariés exposés aux travaux
pénibles des droits des ddd des
bonifications en matière de retraite je
dis cela pour rappeler cette histoire
parce que quand une législation nouvelle
qui croient qu'ils créent un droit qui
me semble un droit fondamental pour les
salariés de ce pays n'a pas pu profiter
n'a pas pu être irriguée par ceux et
celles qui sont les parties prenantes
indispensable à la mise en oeuvre de ce
droit forcément la difficile à la
dispositions arrêtées et difficile à
mettre en oeuvre ça ne remet en cause en
rien sa légitimité son utilité pour des
milliers et presque des millions de
salariés qui leur vie professionnelle
durant son exposé à une pénibilité
terrible et qui toutes les statistiques
le montrent malheureusement quand ils
atteignent l'âge de la retraite sont
très souvent dans des situations
physique qui ne leur laisse que peu de
temps deux pour profiter de cette
retraite donc cela mérite d'être appelé
car vos propositions
dans leur brutalité
consiste à nier ce phénomène consiste à
dire c'est amener vous vous refusez si
nous acceptions s'il a semblé si le
sénat ici même et l'assemblée demain à
accepter vos dispositions il n'y aurait
plus aucun droit plus aucune prise en
compte des travaux pénibles dans les
calculs de la retraite ce serait une
injustice fondamentale
créé à des millions de salariés jeu je
vous mets devant les conséquences de
votre disposition sans aucun esprit
polémique mais il faut assumer des
propositions des décisions pour ce
qu'elles sont deuxième élément je veux
rappeler le dispositif qui a été arrêté
par le gouvernement pour que ce qu'on
pénibilité puissent se mettre en oeuvre
malgré les difficultés que souligne un
certain nombre de 2,2 de représentants
d'entreprises et le gouvernement les
sourds à rien il entend ce qui est dit
pour que c'est que ce combinabilité
puisse être mis en place le mieux
possible le gouvernement a d'abord
demandé un expert de deux de ses sujets
michel de virville qui a eu un passé
dans la vie publique puisqu'il a été je
crois directeur de cabinet d'un ministre
du travail il y aquelques quelques des
années en l'espèce il s'agissait en
effet de jean pierre soisson puis il a
été responsable des ressources ou
secrétaire général d'une très grande
entreprise automobile français donc il
connaît il connaît vraiment bien ces
sujets et
donc michel de virville a proposé la
prise en compte de 10 critères qui
figurait dans la loi avec une recherche
très fine des conditions dans lesquelles
on pouvait individualisé la prise en
compte de c2c de ces critères et
finalement suggéré que pour quatre
d'entre eux qui ne pose aucun problème à
personne
toutes petites entreprises très grosses
entreprises l'application soit immédiate
1er janvier
2015 il s'agit des travaux effectués en
milieu hyperbare du travail de nuit du
travail en équipes successives
alternantes et du travail répétitif là
pour le coup ça pose des difficultés à
personnes génère pas rencontré
d'entreprise qui quand on interroge sur
ces quatre critères la quelle que soit
sa taille nous disent non c'est
difficile d'évaluer les travaux de nuit
de mes salariés non c'est difficile
d'évaluer si mes salariés font des
travaux hyperbare dans ces quatre là l'
affaire est entre guillemets règle et ne
pose pas de difficulté il est vrai que
pour les six critères récent mais il
faut voir les choses telles qu'elles
sont des difficultés demeurent c'est la
raison pour laquelle deuxième décision
du gouvernement il a été de ceux de il a
été
décidé de se donner l'année 2015 pour
étudier pour les port de charges lourdes
pour les postures pénibles pour les
vibrations mécaniques pour le bruit pour
les températures extrêmes et pour les
agents chimiques dangereux les modalités
qui rendrait ce droit applicable le sus
le plus simplement possible il existe
une foule de possibilités
celle ci très probablement peuvent être
expérimentée elle passe par des
solutions qui peuvent être des solutions
de réflexion autour je cite d'ailleurs
pratiquement mot pour mot le commuiqué
qu'on
écrit marisol touraine et françois
rebsamen ya quelques jours quand les
premiers décrets sont parus
cesser ces dispositions peuvent
permettre de réfléchir à un cadre clair
notamment en mettant en oeuvre un
certain nombre d'expérimentations
éventuellement en regardant concrètement
avec les partenaires sociaux les
adaptations nécessaires concernant les
seuils leur mesure et leur mise en
oeuvre travail qui sera réalisé durant
toute l'année 2015 on peut aussi
imaginer des solutions technologiques
car pour ce qui est de l'exposition au
bruit pour ce qui est de l'exposition
aux températures extrêmes pour ce qui
est de des agents chimiques dangereux et
pour ce qui est des vibrations
mécaniques des objets technologiques
bien pensées peuvent permettre
d'enregistrer sans aucune difficulté les
bd les problèmes vécus par les salariés
et peuvent très facilement être
transposée par des dispositifs sur des
ordinateurs et là encore pour des toutes
petites entreprises comme pour des
grosses entreprises on peut trouver des
solutions technologiques pour peu qu'on
soit attaché au dispositif voilà le
rappelle donc exact des conditions de
mise en oeuvre et des difficultés de
mise en oeuvre de ce dispositif que je
voulais faire troisième et dernier point
finalement celui-ci aurait suffi à ce
que le gouvernement donne un avis
défavorable à l'ensemble des
propositions qui sont faites
la simplification
ça n'est pas la disparition d'un certain
nombre de droits voté par le parlement
et ça ne doit pas devenir cela qu'à la
limite certains d'entre vous souhaitent
continuer une bataille parlementaire à
débat parlementaire qu'il n'y a pas
d'agressivité dans mon propos qui a été
tranché mais qui sur lequel finalement
ils sont pas satisfaits de l'arbitrage
soit mais ne faites pas ça quand on
parle de simplification
si la simplification apparaît comme
l'outil de revanche d'un certain nombre
de batailles politiques perdu c'est à la
politique de simplification que vous
rendrez le plus mauvais des services et
est donc parce que la simplification ça
n'est pas la déréglementation parce que
ça n'est pas un droit qu'on doit
détricoter mais c'est au contraire un
doigt qu'on doit rendre plus lisible
plus efficace c'est à ce motif la et
principalement à ce motif la et pour ces
raisons là que le gouvernement d'un avis
défavorable l'ensemble de ces
amendements
merci monsieur le ministre
et j'ai une demande de parole monsieur
après
une explication de vote je crois dire
que les bras m'en tombent parce que nous
accuse souvent d'avoir des positions
principe moi je pense qu'il faut avoir
des positions de principe mais là les
deux groupes ump midi son livre à un
véritable pilonnage
avec des arguments tout à fait
contestable ou et la complexité parlons
de sécurité juridique et même de coût du
travail c'est-à-dire en plaçant le coût
du travail devant la santé des
travailleurs et on voit bien que ce
pilonnage n'a qu'un seul but c'est de
mettre à mort le compte personnel de
prévention de la pénibilité que au nom
de la simplification
c'est bien une mesures de
déréglementation et de remise en cause
d'un des rares points positifs de la loi
sur les retraites de 2014 auquel vous
voulez aboutir à travers ses six
abondement la réalité c'est que depuis
des mois et des mois le lobby patronal
medef en tête ne cessent de faire
pression sur le gouvernement pour
obtenir la mise à mort du comte
pénibilité c'est ça la réalité que vous
relayez madame marisol touraine lors de
son audition par la commission des
affaires sociales très récemment
soulignait elle même que ce chantage
avait assez duré c'est ce que l'on veux
vous dire aussi aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs nous regrettons pour notre
part que le gouvernement ait quelque peu
reculé par exemple avec sur
l'application de six facteurs de
pénibilité sur 10 au 1er janvier 2000
huzz est sûr aussi certaines définitions
de seuils d'exposition qui font que des
salariés qui sont exposés ne pourront
pas faire valoir leurs droits compte
tenu de ces seuils un peu trop
restrictif parce que tel que formaliser
par exemple par le décret du 9 octobre
2014 il excluront certains salariés par
exemple un salarié utilisant un marteau
piqueur deux heures par jour et bien
n'atteindra pas les seuils requis de 450
heures par an aujourd'hui les deux
groupes ump udi en demande plus ce
encore plus c'est toujours plus la seule
boussole semble-t-il sous prétexte de
simplification
semble dette d'exo rinne d'exonérer une
nouvelle fois le patronat de ses
responsabilités sans doute avez-vous en
tête les surcotisation possible de 0 1%
et 0 2% et c'est cela qui vous tracasse
portant et je veux insister là dessus
les questions liées à la santé au
travail sont communément déjà fortement
sous-estimés dans notre pays ainsi on
parle de 10000 à 40000 cancers
professionnels parents beaucoup reste à
faire en réalité pour agir sur la
sous-déclaration des maladies
professionnelles avec les connaissances
les conséquences que vous connaissez
comme moi transfert de charges sur
l'assurance maladie d'ailleurs que très
très partiellement compensée mais aussi
des responsabilisation des entreprises
en matière de prévention est-ce qu'on de
pénibilité c'est bien un compte de
prévention qui sait la meuse était
l'objectif de la disposition faire en
sorte que les salariés soient protégés
et bien suivre vos amendements chers
collègues de des groupes ump et udf
serait envoyé je pense un très mauvais
signal est bafouée en réalité les droits
déjà encore insuffisant des salariés
c'est pourquoi le groupe crc appelle à
voter et appelle la gauche de cet
hémicycle à se mobiliser contre ces
amendements
la parole est à monsieur mohamed soilihi
merci madame la présidente contrairement
à ce qui est affirmé souvent la création
du compte personnel de prévention de la
pénibilité fait suite à une longue
concertation des partenaires sociaux je
crois d'ailleurs le moment venu de
rappeler que c'est le gouvernement
fillon qui a le premier inscrit cette
notion dans la loi sur les retraites du
21 août 2003 à la demande notamment de
la cfdt
l'article 12 de cette loi dispose en
effet dans un délai de trois ans les
organisations professionnelles et
syndicales représentatives au niveau
national sont invités à engager une
négociation interprofessionnelle sur la
définition et la prise en compte de la
pénibilité
cette négociation
contrairement à ce qui est affirmé
aujourd'hui a donc eu lieu elle a duré
fort longtemps pas moins de 18 réunions
ont été organisées
le dispositif de compensation espéré n'a
jamais vu le jour la négociation sur ce
thème entre patronat et syndicats
n'ayant jamais abouti il n'est sans
doute pas inutile de rappeler que le
blocage le blocage est intervenu de la
partie patronale sur le financement ce
n'est pas cela n'a pas empêché le vote
de la loi de 2008 qui a augmenté le
nombre d'annuités nécessaires pour avoir
une retraite à taux plein puis la
fixation en 2010 de l'âge légal de la
retraite à 62 ans dans ces conditions
les partenaires sociaux eux-mêmes ont
demandé au gouvernement de reprendre la
main ce qui a été fait dans le cadre de
la loi de 2013 après une nouvelle
concertation dix critères de pénibilité
ont été définis un dispositif de
compensation a été proposé fondée sur la
formation le temps partiel est le départ
anticipé en retraite il est parfaitement
faux de dire qu aucun dialogue n'a eu
lieu ensuite monsieur de vivre vie a été
missionné pour en faciliter
l'application ça a été précisé tout à
l'heure
seuils ont été rediscuté et quatre
critères objectifs sur les 10 pourront
ainsi être mis en application
l'année prochaine cela ne porte pas à
discussion en revanche les organisations
patronales s'inquiète sur la possibilité
de mesurer les six autres critères c'est
pourquoi monsieur de vie a été missionné
une deuxième fois par le gouvernement
pour étudier avec les partenaires
sociaux la mise en oeuvre de la totalité
du c3 p nous allons donc dans cette
affaire de dialogue et concertation
alors qu'il s'agit d'abord d'appliquer
une loi votée où en est on aujourd'hui
rien n'a changé des résultats des études
réalisées par les experts de la santé au
travail sont d'une grande permanence à
35 ans l'espérance de vie d'un homme est
de 43 ans et d'une femme de 49 ans les
hommes cadres supérieurs ou encore une
espérance de vie de 47 ans soit six ans
de plus qu'un ouvrier les femmes cadres
supérieurs ont une espérance de vie de
51 ans soit deux ans de plus que les
ouvrières cet écart se double d'une
graves inégalités sur l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé les ouvriers sont en
effet atteint de pathologies
invalidantes qui atteignent - les
catégories professionnelles qui n'ont
pas eu à travailler dans le bruit ou à
porter des charges lourdes cette
injustice fondamentale doit être corrigé
actuellement en dehors des maladies
professionnelles reconnues les
conséquences de la pénibilité sont
entièrement prises en charge par la
collectivité au travers des dispositifs
de maladie et d'invalidité
les employeurs sont donc de facto
exonérés de toute participation aux
conséquences financières de la
pénibilité comme s'il s'agissait d'une
fatalité or tel n'est pas le cas
la pénibilité doit être incluse dans les
dispositifs de prévention et le c3 paix
et à cet égard un signal fort en
direction des entreprises afin qu'elles
prennent enfin les mesures nécessaires
qui leur permettront de diminuer leur
contribution
c'est
les personnes de metz le président
retailleau
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
quelques mots d'explication parce que ce
n'est pas anodin ce sont des dispositifs
qui sont importants
simplement je ne veux pas laisser penser
que mon groupe et je crois ni nos
collègues de l'ue des iis sont contre la
pénibilité nous n'avons aucune nous
n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir
comme un de vos collègues vient de
l'indiquer la pénibilité le concept est
entré dans le droit du travail grâce à
la réforme de 2010 c'est grâce à cette
réforme que le lien a été établi entre
la pénibilité et la retraite ne fait pas
penser aux français qu'il n'y a qu'une
façon d'aborder d'approcher la
pénibilité ne fait pas et ne laissait
pas penser les français que
le dispositif allemand est le même que
les dispositifs français monsieur le
ministre je vous mets au défi si vous
voulez si j'ai un peu plus de temps je
vous le démontrerai il ya des
différences qui sont des différences non
seulement deux degrés mais de nature
simplement merci de le reconnaître
simplement nous sommes sur un texte de
simplification
et nous sommes dans une situation où
chaque jour qui passe c'est plus de 500
chômeurs
ou nous savons bien et nous n'avons pas
besoin d'écouter les grandes
confédérations patronales nous avons sur
le terrain des pme et nous sommes à
leurs contacts et ses pme nous disent
tout la même chose que les contraintes
réglementaires administratives en france
sont en train d'étouffer l'emploi donc
permettez que nous prenions ce véhicule
législatif
pour que nous puissions faire entendre
notre voix vous savez nous avons eu tant
de ministres à votre place qui depuis
deux ans et demi nous ont expliqué
doctement péremptoirement que sur le
logement et bien d'autres choses il
avait la panacée pour que quelques mois
près on se rend compte que les mesures
qu'ils présentaient allait à l'encontre
d'intérêt général permettez nous donc de
t et d'affirmer un certain d'opposition
qui sont par ailleurs complètement
cohérent comme l'ont rappelé les
collègues du centre et notamment la vice
présidente catherine de roche pour que
nous puissions faire valoir un certain
nombre d'arguments simplement nous
voulons à la travers ce texte là
réaffirmer que deux dispositifs nous
semble jouer à l'encontre de l'emploi un
dispositif que nous verrons tout à
l'heure le dispositif d'information pour
la succession des entreprises
qui étaient inclus et j'avais à l'époque
lutter vigoureusement contre dispositif
pour les pme pour la transmission c'est
une catastrophe pour les entreprises ça
sera un dispositif on contestera tout à
l'heure qui est dans le texte puisqu'il
était approuvé par la commission après
un amendement de notre collègue jean
jacques hyest et puis elle deuxième
dispositif quel dispositif sur la
pénibilité ce que nous reprochons ce
n'est pas la prise en compte de la
pénibilité nous voulons que la
pénibilité soit prise en compte bien sûr
mais nous contestons formellement la
façon que vous avez de le faire sur le
fond et sur la forme sur le fond parce
que nous pensons très honnêtement qu
effectivement ce sera une usine à gaz et
que c'est le sommet de la complexité dès
le départ pour les petites entreprises
dès lors que il s'agira pour la première
étape du diagnostic elles vont des sites
à plat être confrontés à d'énormes
problèmes et cela continuera et qui dit
complexité administrative dit ni à
contentieux juridique en totale
contradiction avec monsieur le ministre
le choc de simplification que vous
souhaitez faire et je pense que vous
êtes de bonne foi et j'aimerais
d'ailleurs vous convaincre mais par
exemple concept de données collectives
utile comment le décrire et vous qu'est
ce que donnera la jurisprudence dans la
zone est âpre suivant si le conte
pénibilité est appliquée de façon très
précise par rapport à ce que vous
souhaitez nul ne le sait et certainement
pas le gouvernement aujourd'hui sont les
juges qui traceront les dessinant les
contours de ce concept de données
collectives utile ni un contentieux
aussi puisque les risques ont une
technicité extrêmement pointu qu'il est
dit ici le d'aborder sans doute la
jurisprudence tracera là encore un
certain nombre de limites ce sera la
jurisprudence après des contentieux idem
pour les mesures l'actif au seuil
d'autres ceux qui seront créés une
nouvelle complexité donc trop de
complexité un coût du travail direccte
évidemment mais aussi indirects à
travers la charge administrative un
certain nombre de fédérations l'ont
évalué à près de 2 % ça n'est pas rien
on sait que le problème de compétitivité
française c'est aussi le droit du
travail et puis la distorsion bien sûr
de concurrence entre le public et le
privé une fois de plus le privé à des
contraintes que le public n'aura pas
d'ailleurs vous même j'ai relevé une
phrase le 29 octobre que vous avez cités
dans les enjeux les échos j'ai voté la
loi sur la pénibilité qui fonctionne
bien dans d'autres pays entre autres en
allemagne je vous ai dit ce que j'en
pensais mais le ministre que je suis
n'est pas satisfait de cette loi car une
loi qui ne peut pas s'appliquer n'est
pas une bonne loi et sur ce point là je
vous donne raison enfin sur la forme
puisque j'étais sur le fond pour
reprendre ce qu'a dit le collège kadic
un instant et je conclus et bien vous
vous étiez engagé vous avez parlé de
volte face la volte face c'est celle du
gouvernement vous étiez engagé à ce que
les quatre critères qui ne pose pas
problème puisse faire l'objet rapidement
d'un décret pourquoi pas nous n'y sommes
pas opposés en revanche vous étiez
engagé à discuter et michel de virville
devait discuter précisément avant le
décret de sortie sur les six autres
critères vous avez fait une volte face
vous avez rompu votre engagement comment
voulez vous monsieur le ministre de
cette façon là susciter la confiance des
partenaires syndicaux voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire non pas de façon
doctrinaire mais de façon extrêmement
pragmatique la pénibilité bien sûr qu'il
faut la prendre en compte mais ne la
prenons pas en compte de façon aussi
complexe parce qu alors là vous blessez
jusqu'au concept de son application
merci monsieur bout
la parole est à madame briques
oui je viens d'entendre le président
retailleau qui nous dit qu'il est pour
reconnaître la pénibilité mais quand je
lis il exposé des motifs du premier
amendement le 1 rectifié terre c'est
bien l'ensemble du volet pénibilité qui
est contesté donc ne jouez pas sur les
mots je sais que vous êtes habile à le
faire mais il faut voir la réalité de ce
qui est écrit dans l'exposé des motifs
en fait vous contester la légitimité du
dispositif législatif
lancre de la loi à peine sèche et bien
vous en contester et au travers de la
légitimité c'est quasiment la légalité
mais moi je m'étonne plus quand je vois
dans un dans un quotidien qui est plus
lu de ce côté là que de ce côté ci mais
il se trouve que je lis tout est bien
joli cas de nos collègues ne craint pas
de dire que le sénat avec une nouvelle
majorité sénatoriale je cite et dans une
opposition nationale fictif car il est
en fait dans la majorité populaire et
légitime mais dans une minorité légal je
voudrais quand même dire que ça rappelle
des heures assez sombre la différence
entre eux le légitime et légal le pays
réel et le pays formelle parce que vous
nous fait un procès d'intention tout à
l'heure même si je note un progrès parce
que maintenant nous écoutons les grandes
entreprises mais pas les petites comme
d'autres collègues ici avec mes
collègues seine-et-marne et nous avons
reçu les représentants de la cgpme de
notes département et je pense que
d'autres l'ont fait nous les avons
entendus c'était avant c'était avant ce
sont des chefs d'entreprises qui sont à
la cgpme de mon département en tout cas
c'est le cas et c'était avant que le
gouvernement fasse sa proposition qui a
été concertée des quatre critères
applicables au 1er janvier 2015 et des
autres c'était avant et les mêmes était
satisfait d'avoir été entendus par le
gouvernement alors il faut pas nous
faire ce procès vous nous faites vous
nous dites tout le temps vous irez vous
les entreprises vous ne les connaissez
pas vous les socialistes vous n'aimez
pas les entreprises de la même manière
que quand nous allons discuter du plfss
vous nous direz que nous n'aimons pas
les familles c'est bien connu mais quand
j'entends
sur ses bancs qu'on nous dit et de le
président balles a dit tout à l'heure
lui à la tribune ou en tout cas en
intervention liminaire et vous l'avez
repris monsieur k dick le fait que ça
renchérit c'est le coût du travail mais
c'est une assertion complètement
gratuite sur quelles bases
explicite vous vous fondez je voudrais
quand même vous rappeler que cice
plus pacte de responsabilité
ces 42 milliards en faveur des
entreprises et le premier ministre a mis
aujourd'hui en place le comité
d'évaluation des baisses de charge
toutes les baisses de charges avec les
partenaires patronaux et syndicaux qui
étaient tous là alors ne venez pas nous
dire que ça renchérit le coût du travail
qu'en 42 milliards sont accordés aux
entreprises pour qu'elles restaurent
leur compétitivité pour l'emploi pour
les embauches et pour l'investissement
on verra ce qu'il en sera dans un an de
cette mise en place de ces meutes de ces
dispositions alors moi je crois
c'est ça qui est posée par les
amendements vous comprendrez bien que ce
n'est pas acceptable et que nous ne
l'acceptons pas
à la robe
rappel aux grands romans pour monsieur
retailleau
écoutez on veut faire un rappel au
règlement
vous avez cité un quotidien
vous avez cité un de nos collègues et
bien moi je vais donner son nom
c'est le président de la commission des
affaires sociales alain briques oui ou
non
bien
et vous avez dans une phrase tenté
d'assimiler ces propos tenter si tenté
d'assimiler ce propos je cite aux heures
les plus sombres de notre histoire
franchement franchement est-ce qu'on est
à ce point à bout d'arguments pour oser
une comparaison pour oser une
comparaison entre un collègue que l'on
connaît tous bien président de la
commission des affaires sociales et sept
périodes les plus sombres de notre
histoire franchement ça n'est pas
raisonnable donc je pense que que les
uns et les autres nous soyons passionnés
dans la soutenance de nos arguments
c'est parfaitement normal mais ce que je
demande ce que je demande c'est que nous
puissions avancer des arguments sans
jamais mettre en cause nos collègues
sans jamais utiliser des procédés qui
voudraient les disqualifier quand on a
du mal à avancer des arguments
précisément pour contrer les arguments
que nous mêmes nous avançons voilà c'est
un rappel au règlement et je souhaite
madame la présidente qu' on puisse
et que vous puissiez jouer votre rôle
pour calmer ces débats qui mérite je
pense une autre auteur que celle à
laquelle on vient d'assister mais nous
allons poursuivre ses débats
sereinement avec l'intervention de
monsieur k dick
merci et pour venir compléter
l'intervention dessus retailleau
d'ailleurs je le remercie et salue son
intervention bien évidemment au groupe
udi personne n'a parlé de faire
disparaître la pénibilité ça ça a été
vraiment je suis totalement interloqué
par les réactions tout ce que j'ai
entendu enfin très honnêtement c'est
vrai que je suis là depuis pas très
longtemps mais je suis vraiment suis
sidéré
est ce une loi de simplification une loi
de complications parce que si on est
bien en train de parler d'une loi de
simplification et ben alors oui il faut
repenser fondamentalement la mise en
place de ce volet pénibilité voilà si
c'est la simplification et je crois
qu'on est là pour ça
six mois en tant qu'entrepreneur je vous
dis qu'effectivement ça serait un enfer
pour les entreprises je vous le dis en
tant qu'entrepreneur aussi
7 à
l'effet on l'a dit serait dévastateur
pour l'emploi et puis certains disent
que ça serait aussi dévastateur qui l'a
été et que l'on était les 35 heures
madame briques
quand je dis que ça va renchérir le coût
du travail mais si les formalités ne
coûte rien alors à quoi sert la
simplification
c'est bien pour faire justement des
économies enfin moi il m'avait semblé
entendre ça de la part du ministre voilà
donc
le premier ministre nous a dit qu'il
aimait les entreprises
si ce soir nous votons nous abrogerons
les articles comme nous l'avons proposé
est bien du jeu c'est que les
entreprises aimeront ce que nous avons
fait et je crois que c'est ça ira
peut-être dans le sens de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure et si
effectivement le gouvernement va dans ce
sens là il sera aimé par les entreprises
merci pour la parole est
président le noir
bien merci madame la présidente monsieur
mailly mes chers collègues je suis assez
surpris pour dire la vérité un peu
heurtée par l'argumentation que le
ministre a soutenu il ya un instant à
vous entendre monsieur le ministre cette
loi doit être examiné dans un cadre
extrêmement restreint il faut se
contenter de simplifier vous avez même
souligné qu'ils ne feraient pas
convenable de revenir sur des
dispositions
adoptées il y à peu par le parlement
vous ne pouvez que confirmer ce que vous
avez dit
alors monsieur le ministre vous êtes
tout simplement un sophiste
le mot n'est pas injurieux
le sophisme dans l'antiquité était une
forme d'éloquence très prisé
par les philosophes qui consistait à
utiliser le même argument pour soutenir
une chose et son contraire
et certains ils ont excellé c'est
aristote qui a mis fin car la logique ni
trouvé plus son compte vous êtes un
sophiste parce que l'argument que vous
avez soutenu à l'instant
va vous être retourné à l'article 7
que dit l'article 7 de votre projet de
loi
je résume sans caricaturer il faut
détricoter la loi lure la loi lui
requête est votée par une majorité
soutenue par un gouvernement vous même
avez voté cette loi l'assemblée
nationale
cette loi est tout à fait récente or le
gouvernement prenne l'initiative de
remettre en cause ces dispositions alors
pourquoi voulez vous nous empêchez par
cet argument qui est un argument
fallacieux car c'est là l'essence même
du sophisme nous opposer la possibilité
que l'on aurait de remettre en cause des
dispositions récentes quand vous même
vous prenez la responsabilité au grand
dam de madame duflot de le faire sur
d'autres textes dont monsieur le
ministre
admettez que lorsqu'on parle de la
simplification de la vie des entreprises
on puis simplifiée et compris en
abrogeant des dispositions qui ont
malencontreusement fait finalement
l'opinion du gouvernement était adopté
il ya seulement quelques semaines
plus personne ne demande la parole
donc j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe ump sur les
amendements identiques numéro 1 rectifié
qu'inquiets c'est numéro 40 de rectifier
quater je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est favorable
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
je vais donc vous donner les résultats
du scrutin concernant les deux
amendements un numéro en rectifier
quinquis et numéro 40 de rectifier
quater nombre de votants
339 nombre de suffrages exprimés
339 pour l'adoption
187 contre
150,2 les deux amendements sont donc
adopté